hello everyone i will now present my
joint to work with dorita haranov
where you prove two combinatorio ama
complete problems
we know that there are a number of
settings where randomness helps a lot
so for instance we cannot imagine
cryptography if you're not able to pick
a randomly
fresh secret key
but on the other hand we know other
settings where we expect
randomness not to help so for example we
know that uh
if pseudorandom number generators exist
and this is implied by several widely
believed
circular bombs then every problem that
can be solved with
randomized algorithms in polynomial time
can also be
solved by deterministic ones
so we are an embarrassing point where
the this
type of statements because bpp uh should
be true
but it has been open for decades and the
focus of our result is trying to
understand this uh
need or not uh this need of randomness
in the nondeterministic setting
so more specifically we're interested in
an m a versus np problem
so almost all of you should know what np
is but let me just recall it
uh we say that the language is in np if
you have a deterministic polynomial time
deterministic algorithm d
that receives two to inputs x it is an
instance that you want to decide if it's
a positive or negative instance of this
problem
and a proof why and we want this
algorithm
that uh like this algorithm has the
following properties
we know that for all positive instances
there must exist a proof that makes this
our deterministic hours of accept
but for no instances no matter which
proof is given to this
deterministic polynomial time algorithm
it should reject
since np uh is a cornerstone of
classical complexity theory
we it has been extended to different
settings so for instance in the
randomized setting
where we have m a that stands for merlin
arthur
the definition of m a is it
follows closely at p so now we have
still have an input and a proof but now
we have a polynomial time randomized
algorithm
that should accept or reject x
and in the definition of ma we can say
that
if there exists for yes instances
their system y that makes this
randomized algorithm to always accept
and you can assume it with uh without
loss of generality
and for no instances we want that for
every proof that is given to this
randomized algorithm this
hour should reject with high probability
as in p versus bpp we we also believe
that these two problems
are are the same and this is the
non-deterministic and the randomization
the the randomization conjecture and
these are implied by the existence of
pseudonym generators uh believable or
circular bombs
but again the the problem if m a equals
and b
is still an open wide problem
one way of trying to solve this
conjecture is trying to
pick to pick an m a complete problem and
showing that there's ma a complete
problem is np
but uh one one problem with this uh
with this um approach is that
the problem uh uh the main was defined
in the 80s
but since 2008 no ma complete problem
was known
and braventer how they showed the first
complement
problem coming from quantum computing
later other mma complete problems were
also
developed but again in these um
in the context of quantum computation or
at least uh with a quantum notation
so this makes us wonder if is this a
fundamental
problem that is this is a fundamental
point that all make
problems come from quantum computing or
can we find new
combinatorial uh m a country problems
that have nothing to do with uh with
quantum
and this is the main question that that
we that we
tackle in our in our paper so
in our work what we do is first we pre
we
propose two new problems and the first
problem
is an extension of csps to
what you call set constraint
satisfaction problems
so the idea is that now we have
constraints not on a string or but on a
set of strings
and on set on a set of strings yeah
and we want to know if there exists a
set assignment
for these constraints that
that satisfies all of them or for all
set assignments there is
an epsilon fraction of them that is not
it's fine
the second problem that we that we
propose
is nothing related to that like it has a
very different um
definition and it asks about finding
connect
clean connect components on graph so let
me be a bit more explicit
we the input to this problem is an
implicit
description of a graph so we have a
circuit that tells
all the the neighbors of of a given node
and we're also given an implicit
description of a function that marks all
of these vertices
and we want to decide if they're between
the cases if there exists a kinetic
component
where all these vertices all the
vertices and disconnected components
are marked or we want to approximate
this this property meaning that for any
set s
either there is an epsilon fraction of
these vertices that are marked
or the set is epsilon far from being an
economic component meaning that
there exists a a lot of edges that leave
this set s
and with these two problems in hand we
have the following results
so first we showed that uh the set csp
problems
uh is actually any hard for
for an inverse polynomial parameter
epsilon
secondly we show that we can reduce set
csp
to this approximately clean approximate
connector component problem
and finally we show that for every
polynomial p uh
this approximate clean approximate
connect component is in a main
so these three results together says
that we can show that
uh this acac and set csu set csp
problems
are made complete so we finally showed
two
new m a complete problems that are uh
that
have nothing to do with quantum and they
are defined and proved on
only with only combinatorial
combinatorial tools
so now i'll give you a bit more details
of how to
how to achieve these three steps and
i'll start by the third one so
uh let me give more details on
this acac problem so as i said
the graph is given implicitly so we
assume that the set of vertices are all
n-bit strings and the set of edges
i are described by a polynomial size
circuit c that
given a vertices it outputs the
uh at most polynomially many neighbors
of v
furthermore we have also another
polynomial size
circuit m that uh also gets us an
input one of the vertices but now it
puts just a bit
that tells if this vert if this vertex
is marked or not
and as i mentioned before we want to
distinguish yes and always this is where
yes in yes instances there exists a
kinetic component
that is a mark so all vertices in this
connected component
are marked from the case where all sets
of
all sets of vertices are either have
either
a lot of marked elements or they expand
well so there are a lot of connections
between the set of vertices and
everything that's outside of it
um so as i said we showed that acac is
in mma
and our ma verification is uh
the following so the prover just gives
initial strings at zero
and using the implicit description of
this graph
the verifier just performs a random walk
on it
and if at any point uh the
verifier this random wall passes by a
marked element then the verifier decides
to reject
so we can easily show completeness uh
because
if there exists a clean connect
component so a connect component with
all with where all the vertices are
marked then the approver can send any
vertex of this
connected component and the rondo walk
does not leave it so
the renault walk never reaches a marked
element
and therefore therefore the random walk
never the very fire never ejects
soundness uh we have that from this
properties of no instances
that every set of uh unmarked strings
it has a lot of um
expansion so with little so the
probability of leaving the set is
is very large so with this property we
can show that
for uh any random walk start in any
vertex
we reach about a marked string with a
very high probability
and therefore we can improve uh the
soundness
of the semi verification
and this ends the proof or the sketch of
proof that they see ac is in mma
we now switch gears to the second
problem that we propose in our work
which is called setcsp as i previously
mentioned
this problem is an extension of standard
csps to
this to know to the notion of a set
constraint satisfaction problems and
because of that let us recall
standard csps and here
we have that an assignment is a n-bit
string and we want to choose this
assignment that satisfies all the
clauses
and the clauses here they can be seen
just as allowed substrings
so for instance a clause ci could tell
that uh
bits i and k they they it could have the
value 0 0 0 1
and 1 1 but it could not have the
substring
1 0 for instance and you want
they said they want to choose an
assignment that satisfies all the
clauses that
sorry such that all the substrings are
allowed
on the set csp setting we now
have assignments that are sets of
strings so there you have a subset of
all the possible and bit strings and now
the constraints they're not only allowed
the strings but they're allowed
sets so let me
be a bit more concrete so by an example
so if you have a constraint set
constraints
ci we now have two sets and these sets
must be disjoined
and here we see that we have a set 0 0
and 1 1
and the second set 0 1. and now
the set a set of strings being satisfied
by a constraint is a bit more
complicated
and i'll try to explain it uh by an
example
so we say that a set for instance that
if you have the cons the constraint c1
was uh that is defined as i said before
the
first set zero zero one one and the
second allowed set is zero one
and let us see what happens if you have
the assignment let's say s1 that is
1 1 0 and 0 run 1.
and the first requirement is that the
substring of
each string in the set appears in
some set of c1 and here everything is
fine because we have
one one in the first set and zero one in
the second set
but on the other hand if you consider
the set as two we have or
have two strings one one zero and one
zero one one one zero is fine
because one one is here like on bits one
one and two
but one zero one is not good so it's not
satisfying the set constraint
because the because the substring one
zero doesn't appear in any allowed
subset
the set constraint it's it tells uh okay
the first one is allow a
set constraint is telling what are the
allowed strings in the set
but now we have a stronger notion that
tells
uh strings that should come together so
for example uh also i'll go
i'll keep the same constraint but now
let's say
if you have a the set s1 if you have the
string
one one zero since one one
comes always with zero zero so if they
appear in the same allowed set
what we also require is that if we
replace one one
uh by zero zero this the remaining
string that
zero zero zero because we keep the third
bit or all the remaining bits
it should also be the set as one
if and for example if you have just a
single tone then it does not change
anything right
if you have zero one you the this thing
does not have any neighbor
in this allowed set so by or on its own
it is okay in this set and just to say
how would be an example where it does
not happen so for instance if you have
s2
that does not contain this string 0 0 0
then the set s 2 is not good
because if you have this thing 1 1 0
this string is uh missing the string
0 0 0 because 0 0 and 1 1 appearing the
same allowed set
so here i just wanted to give a glimpse
of how what it means
by uh set constraint to satisfy like a
set to satisfy a set constraint or not
and as a and just to to be a bit more
concrete
as i said set csps is an extension of
csps
and this is the case because you you can
convert csps to set csps
where all the sets are singleton so all
the allowed sets
just contain one element and in this
case this
second um restriction it does not appear
anymore and then you have standard space
but but the power that do that that
comes from from from that csps
is indeed having more than one more than
a singleton here
and this will allow us to prove any
hardness as i'll tell shortly
so as i said uh what we show is that
set csp is any hard but before going to
that we have to define
some notation so we we tell that
a set s has the onset value
according to some clause ci and this
value is just the number of strings that
violate the properties
um for this constraint ci so either
strings
that are now not not in an allowed
subset
or strings that are missing a second
string that are not in this uh
this set s and in order to keep it
normalized we also
we divide this uh we divide this number
of
uh strings violating ci by
the number of strings in a set
and uh we just generalized it for
for the onset value for this set
according to the
of to the all set constraints and this
is just
the the the average
of the unset value for every cr
so a bit more concrete in our result now
we showed that there exists simple nlp
such that
if you're given as input set constraints
then we show that it is only hard to
decide if there are existence at
s that has unset value equal zero so a
set
s that satisfies all the constraints
or for every set of strings
the unset value of these uh of this set
of
uh uh that there's onset value according
to this all all of these constraints
should be above some inverse polynomial
so it's very far
it's it's some somewhat far from from
being satisfied
and now i'll try to give a glimpse of
how improving my hardness
of this of this problem
and but in order to do that let me give
a step back and
go back to the np completeness and claim
ethereum
and see it in a different way
so in the quick learning theorem we
first start from a boolean circuit
so it has some input you have some gates
and you
have output bit and the question is is
there
assignment to the input variables so
that when you
when you propagate these inputs you have
the output one
and the way the quick leveling theorem
goes in
like a different way of seeing it is
that you have you can you
want to consider the history string of
the circuit so you want to
assign like these variables to all of
these um
to all of the wires and see them as a
string
right so we put all of them together and
you want that uh
to add constraints so you want in the
csp you add constraints
that indeed check if the the correct
positions
are form a correct um
history of this circuit so let's
for instance the bit corresponding to z1
should be the end of y1
and y2 and this constraint so as i said
they should check two things so first
that that these variables
have the consistent values and secondly
the the
output bit is one so
the first o at first would be attempted
to say okay what happens if
so this works for np but for this to
work for
m a we should replace these variables by
a random value
right so the idea is that we should
replace them by some values are one up
toward our
let's say k and
would be attempted to say that oh then
then you you could try to to use the
same
uh the same reduction to have a history
string
but here the crucial point is that how
can we ensure
that the these imp these random input
bits are indeed
input uh are needed random and
why aren't they adversarially chosen
and in order to enforce that you indeed
have random bits
that's how we we use set constraints
um but so let me extend this notion of
history string to the notion of history
set
and uh to show any hardness we need a
bit
more structure so instead of having just
a boolean circuit
we want now it to be reversible but
that's no worry because
we can do it without loss of generality
if you had some
uh auxiliary input zero and we choose a
gate set that
is reversible and luckily the there is
so if you have not
and the cc not gates they they they are
universal uh gate set for classical
computation that is reversible
and now instead of having a history
strings
what our idea is to put every snapshot
of your of the computation in what you
call a history set
so we want to collect all the snapshots
of the computation
for all possible random values but
in order to do that we want that the
snapshot of step
zero not to to be mixed with snapshot of
s1
so because of that will you append a
prefix that tells what's the timestamp
of that
of that snapshot so for instance if you
have a time zero
we have uh one one zero zero zero as the
input
then at step uh at time step one and
we for for technical reasons we put uh
the the clock like this timestamp the
clock register
uh as uh in in unity so
if you have this input at time zero then
you should have one zero
zero one one one zero zero uh
as a snapshot of time 2. and
and with this so we have this random
value 0 0 here and then we we can
add all the steps of the computation to
this history set
and the point is that we we do this for
not only for
the value zero zero for the random coins
but then we read for every possible
value so
we do all the all the the the snapshots
when the random when the random coins
are for instance zero one and one zero
and one one and so on
and what we were able to show is that
you can add set constraints
that verify if this if the history set
is at least close to be correct
meaning that uh this is the set contain
strings who that first the the the clock
register is correct
then that uh at time stand zero you have
that you one that all the
auxiliary bits they start with uh like
they they are initialized to zero for
instance
uh third and one of the most important
parts we want to show that
uh the history set contain the history
of computations for
all random coins
and finally as in the npks we then check
if
this history set contains all the all
the computations so all
all the snapshots are there and then the
output
snapshot contains the output bit one
so these are the set constraints and i
won't dive into the details what they
they really mean but i just like to
point out that
these uh this uh set constraint that uh
that
uh check if all random values there are
there and
they they say that at time zero if you
have a random bit zero
you should also have the random bit one
and vice versa
so this is the key point that allows us
to enforce that
all random coins should be in the
history set
and this finishes the proof or at least
uh
the glimpse of the proof that such as p
is
any hard now
the only remaining part is showing a
reduction from set csp
to acac
here so we assume that to have a set csp
instance con
that is consist of
m set constraints and then we consider
the implicit graph where the
vertices as i said is the are the n-bit
strings
and we consider two strings to be
adjacent if there exists some
some i such that these strings are
neighbors via
ci so this uh this means that these two
strings are neighbors
if they should appear together in the
set assignment for this cons for the set
csp
and notice that this can be computed in
polynomial time
so we can create we can give an implicit
description of the graph
but for the input of acic we also need
this implicit description of the
function
that marks some vertices and we say that
this
this bit string is marked if and only if
uh z is not in one of the allowed sets
of c i
so z is a string that
should not be in the in the construct in
the assignment
for the set csp
so given this reduction what we're able
to show is that if there is some set s
such that it satisfies all set
constraints
then s is a connected component in g
and moreover s contains only a marked
strings
so it means that if this set constraint
the set csp instance is satisfiable
then the graph the graph has a connected
component
that is a marked
second we show that if for every s then
the onset value of
s according to to this set csb instance
is at least
epsilon then for every string first
every set s
it contains at least epsilon where two
fraction of marked strings or the
expansion
uh for the set so the number of
neighbors is at least that's an average
and this shows that if you have a no
instance of the c set csp
then you also have no instance of the of
the acac problem
and uh therefore since we know that said
csp
is mahar in acacs in mma
then what to show that acac and set csp
rma complete for
for when the gap of the premise gap for
both problems is inverse polynomial
so let me just conclude with some
further work and open questions
so by using the same uh arguments that
uh dorito haranov and i had in our in
2019
paper what we can show that if you if
instead of considering
inverse polygap set csp if you consider
constant gap set csps
then this problem is actually an np
so in other words what
it can show that if you have some sort
of
set psp theorem so a gap amplification
for set csps
then we can actually show that ma goes
in v and
the the backward direction is direct
because uh we have a pcp
here for np so this shows that if you
want to show that ma cos np
there is actually a
a very concrete way of doing that by
showing gap modification for set csps
however we cannot show that uh gap acac
in np
and this is a is an interesting open
problem
and our goal is that with our two
combinatorial and
complete problems we can now show that
many more problems are actually made
complete and
hopefully use them to to show that
m a goes in v so thank you for attention